hollywood's version of the beauty salon
is well documented but the reality comes
at a cost adding to an already
overflowing waste stream
millions of pounds of hair foil plastic
and metals head out the back doors of
salons and into landfills every year but
now many are joining a movement to get
that material recycled and reused
helping the look and feel of both their
loyal customers and the planet
whether it's a hair salon in brooklyn
new york or one in the atlanta suburbs
the scene is certainly familiar
color cuts and blowouts
but what's beautiful for the individual
is not for the environment
i think that a lot of clients don't
realize how much waste a salon produces
10 000 pounds of oils a day are going
into our landfill every little bit of
leftover color
jennifer barber is general brand manager
for the southern based bob steel salons
which in the last year became certified
sustainable meaning they recycle 95
percent of their waste
we felt it was the right thing to do to
support our community and be a leader
and make sure that we're doing what's
right to lower our carbon footprint
something that has resonated with
customers like lauren ramsey does it
matter to you that to know that the
salon recycles all that it does
absolutely i've been a customer here for
about 15 years so it's one of the best
things about this place i think every
company should make efforts to be
environmentally friendly and green i
think that's just the way the world is
this day
the bob steel salons aren't recycling on
their own they're a part of the green
circle salons a collaborative formed to
make recycling as easy and affordable as
possible for individual shops
this is where
most of our recycling happens you can
see these are the green circle boxes
that we have here do you think you could
do this if you were just doing it on
your own no not too not after learning
how they do it and the amount of
recycling that we're doing i can say at
least at one of our smallest salons i'm
doing a box every other day where i'm
filling it and able to ship it off i
mean our large salon in atlanta that has
34 chairs we're producing you know five
boxes a week or more in recycling
all coming here
so we're at the green circle salons
illinois facility and this is where we
receive all of the waste from salons
across the united states shane price is
the founder and ceo kind of see the
bales of foil right there the idea for
green circle was sparked when the
entrepreneur and outdoorsman was looking
for his next project needing a haircut
and stepped into a salon for the very
first time
i randomly kind of picked the salon i
went to the salon i sat down and and i
had this moment of surprise and shock to
see the amount of garbage that was
building up in the salon and just simply
being thrown out sent to landfill and so
as we dug into the issue we came to
realize that this wasn't an isolated
case in my salon right but in fact it's
a situation that's endemic to the salon
industry
and the numbers were staggering
every single minute salons are throwing
about 877 pounds of waste into landfill
every minute every minute that's about
half a million pounds a day and what's
shocking about that is 95 of that
is recyclable it can go back into
circulation and back into our economy
and create value
it's a message and a mission which price
has been sharing ever since
we've built a wastewater community of
salon professionals who have shared and
helped us to shape and build this
program so that it works inside this
industry simple as let's find a
recycling plant that will do this for us
oh for sure
for sure find the first salon for sure
it was two feet in a heartbeat knocking
on doors getting told to you know just
leave this along where you we don't take
solicitors yeah and me kind of pushing
through a little bit and saying listen
i'm not here to sell you anything i'm
here to pick up your hair clippings and
your foils thinking yes i was throwing
the waste in my car in the back of my
car for sure and taking it to the
recycling company i think at one time
yeah we stored the hair clippings in a
barn in the early days
it's coming a blob of oil possibly 2
million gallons creeping to shore
threatening to become america's worst
environmental disaster in 2010 green
circle was able to get those hair
clippings down to the gulf of mexico to
aid in the bp oil spill cleanup
publicity from that would help launch
the business in the u.s
now 13 years after its founding there
are about 4 000 green circle affiliated
salons across the u.s and canada so this
is recycled plastic and recycled hair
that's been combined to form a new type
of bio-composite material
this is the hair fiber right here
but the company's growth has gone beyond
its salon partners and into the
sustainability sphere we've explored
different possibilities with hair right
now we've made a biocomposite material
working alongside virginia tech this
brings recycle plastics and recycled
hair together to make this new
formulation and we're able to make these
recycling bins that go back into salons
in addition to that we have worked and
are working with a research group in
california to understand how we can turn
hair into a keratin soup into an amino
acid soup and use these amino acids as a
biostimulant for agricultural purposes
price says it's a necessary shift in our
collective thinking to see all waste as
a resource
so whether it's mass or capes gowns all
of this is just plastic that can be
shredded and can be re-pelletized into
pellets plastic beads and then turned
into new ppe and new products that you
know we need to use so hair chemical
dies i didn't even know that could be
recycled all right so we work with our
partners to separate these chemicals a
water layer and an oil layer okay the
water layer can be neutralized into salt
and water and go right back into the
wastewater grid safely the oil layer is
refined a little bit and actually fuel
the system that powers this process to
happen at the plant
and while green circle works to reduce
the eco footprint of salons its own
impression has expanded including beauty
brands like l'oreal and redkin in the
mission and each one of these brands has
their own initiative some of them we
plant trees with
some of them we do work with ocean
plastic and getting ocean plastic out of
the oceans when we bring all of these
sort of stakeholders together again the
salon owners or the spa owners their
staff the manufacturers of the products
it's only together that we could build
the right solutions that addresses
everybody's needs and at the same time
dramatically reduces the impact of the
planet thank god you needed a haircut
that day thank god i needed a haircut
that day yeah
and i know a lot of people are warning
so what does it cost me because if i'm
going to go to one of these salons so
here's what's interesting bob steel
salons we went to they're not passing
cost along to their customer they
obviously have to pay green circle but
what i was told is it ends up being
about two dollars a client is is what
that would cost which if you're going
and spending 200 already to get your
hair colored whatever it may be it's a
very minimal cost if it's passed on but
obviously the impact is huge they are
actually recycling also they say they
recycle 95 of the material they are b
corp and zero waste certified which
means an independent group has gone
through and made sure they're actually
recycling the things they say that they
are recycling yeah accountability if
yeah if we don't pay the cost now
we're going to end up paying it later
yeah look he told me that there are
thousands of landfills that will be at
capacity by 2035 if we don't take care
of them see good things happen
conversations in salons and barber shops
that's true always